- I had a sort of secret
desire as a high schooler
to be a comedian.
I didn't know what that meant.
There is no secret society out there,
that will tap you on
the shoulder one night
and show you the way.
We're working really hard
to make jokes about ideas.
The lawyer for Google
would read these statements
that I said on air
and I said, well I didn't say that.
- He's an American comedian,
writer, actor, and tv host.
He currently hosts a late night
television talk show on CBS.
His book, I am American and So Can You,
was number one on the New
York Times, best seller list.
He's Stephen Colbert
and here is my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number six is my personal favorite
and make sure sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Stephen is talking,
if he says something
that really inspires you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
(upbeat music)
- We'd only been on 32.
I think we hadn't even done 50 shows.
- Wow.
- And so, I call Jon Stewart and said,
Jon, I just got invited for
the correspondents dinner,
do you think I should do it?
And he said, what, to like attend?
And I said, no, they want me.
'cause they want you to be the guy?
Like to stand next to the president?
Do they know what you do?
And I said, I don't know.
And I said, I think I have to do it.
You have to do it!
Like right now, you have to do it.
So don't pay attention to
the approval ratings that say
68% of Americans disapprove of the job
this man is doing.
I ask you this,
does not that also logically mean
that 68% approve of
the job he's not doing?
(audience laughing)
Think about it, I haven't.
- Why did comedy kind of become
of your thing, do you think?
Or did comedy kind of pick you?
- Well that's a nice way of putting it.
That's a nice way of putting it.
I would say,
I can't under emphasize
how important comedy's been to my life
and how important certain opportunities
that came along to my life
and they all, many of them
seem sort of accidental.
For instance, like second city,
I didn't think I was
going to be a comedian.
I had a sort of secret
desire as a high schooler
to be a comedian.
I didn't know what that meant.
You know, I just really liked being funny
and from one of 11 kids
and we're a funny family
and being funny is important.
The king of the room was who
ever was funniest, you know?
And I remember as a child,
I seen comedy help, my
family had a tragedy
when I was younger,
my father and two of my brothers died
and I remember my sister making
another one of my sisters
laugh so hard on the way,
the car away from the cemetery.
One of my sisters made the other sister
laugh so hard that she fell
on the floor of the limo.
When of those big floors
with the rumble seat facing each other
and she fell on the floor laughing
and I remember thinking,
I want to do that.
And I don't know whether
it was specifically
when the context of dealing with tragedy
because I don't think, I was also 10,
but I remember specifically thinking,
I want that, I would have loved
to been able to do that right now
and then I fell asleep
every night for years
listening to Bill Cosby,
Wonderfulness, Very Funny Fellow,
David Frye, Richard Nixon, A Fantasy,
George Carlin and Class Clown,
Let's Get Small, Wild and Crazy Guy,
back when you could stack albums.
Stack so many of them, the
top one kind of played slow
as it went around
and then I went to college to be an actor.
But an actor actor.
I wore black and I had a beard
and you know, I was like, let
me share my misery with you.
(audience laughing)
Poets slash jerk kind of actor.
And then I accidentally met
some people from second city
and took some classes there
and got invited to audition
and accidentally.
Just sort of a happy accident,
fell in with some great people
and I still, I quit second city four times
in order to go do straight black box,
avant garde kind of theater in Chicago.
Which that was what I was going to be.
I was going to live in a studio apartment
with no furniture and
a futon on the floor,
that I stuffed myself with yak fur
and just drank and be single,
with the beard and you
know, sandals and a dashiki
and I was going to drink from a san malvar
that was constantly
bubbling in the background.
But one day I was back stage
and I kept on returning to do comedy
and I was backstage one night
and this is really the thing
that made the decision for me.
I was backstage with a
guy named Dave Risowski,
who does a,
what's it called?
He does podcast, does a great podcast.
What do you kids do, your podcasts?
He's a great guy.
We're backstage, somebody was on stage
and they were supposed to
do a very simple blackout.
And a blackout is a very short,
it's got one joke and
then the lights go out.
This is second city.
It's a pace keeper for the show.
She goes out there and
the blackout is this,
she goes, you know.
You're supposed to say,
I'd like to do a song for you now.
Welcome to the no exit cafe.
I'd like to do a song for you right now.
A song for the whales.
You tune up your guitar for a long time.
This is a song for the whales.
And then you go,
(terrible whale noises)
very simple, you do whistling
and clicks and everything.
It's fine, not a big, not a great laugh
but it works every time.
She goes out there to do it.
I'd like to do a song for you right now.
She goes into her
whistling and her clicking
and we're backstage waiting to go on
for the next scene, me and Dave,
and we're not getting any laughs.
This is foolproof.
No laughs at all, what's going on?
Something's wrong.
And then she goes,
oh I forgot, it's song for whales.
(audience laughing)
And we burst into laughter backstage
and we threw our arms around each other
in the agony of her failure.
And we're just laughing.
We fell like a collapsing teepee.
We just fell to the ground
and Dave's feet went out
onto stage like this,
as we held each other like lovers.
The most intimate, joyful
experience at her pain,
that we all knew
and she could hear it happen
and the audience could see our feet
and she started laughing at how
wonderfully she had just failed.
And I thought at that moment,
this is what I want.
If failure of this scale
can cause this much joy for anyone,
than this is the healthiest
thing that I could do
with the rest of my life
and I will do nothing else
and I have never looked
back from that moment.
- What is the goal?
In your mind, what was the
goal of political satire?
- To make people laugh.
You know, I would make
jokes about politics
because my model was the news
and I care about politics
and I care about current events
and I'll always do jokes about that.
I mean, the new show has that as well.
We're definitely, that's
big part of the new show,
especially going into a
presidential election.
But the goal is to make people laugh.
I mean, politics is
incredibly frustrating,
the news can be incredibly depressing.
If we just make your
day a little bit better,
you know, at the end,
because we make jokes that show,
yeah, we feel the same way you do or like,
or rather we curate for you,
our feelings about the news
and maybe you agree with our jokes
or what's funny about the day's news.
That sense of connection between
the performer and the audience
is the entire intention.
You know, why does anybody,
what does anybody want?
Not to be alone
and I think a performer gets on stage
and says the things that are in his mind,
in is own particular way,
to me a connection with an audience
so he doesn't feel so alone.
And hopefully the audience
feels the same way.
It's not conscious, it's here, not here.
And so that's got to be the goal.
That connection's got to be the goal
and the making somebody
laugh has got to be the goal.
You can't think that you're
satire is going to change things.
Peter Cook famously said,
a great satirist, worked
with Dudley Moore,
and in beyond the fringe,
he famously said that the greatest satire
of the 20th century,
was the Vimart Caberet
and boy, they just stopped
Hitler in their tracks.
You know, you can't imagine,
however great your joke is,
that it's going to change things.
What it does is
just make a connection with any audience
who's feeling the same way you do.
While traditional paths
may seem harder to find,
that also means that you may learn,
sooner than most generations,
the hard lesson that you must
always make the path for yourself.
There is no secret society out there,
that will tap you on
the shoulder one night
and show you the way.
Because the true secret is,
your life will not be defined
by the society we have left you.
To paraphrase Robert Bolt,
society has no more idea of what you are,
than what you do.
Because ultimately, it has
only your brains to think with.
Every generation must define itself
and so make the world that suits itself.
So, if you must find your own path
and we have left you no easy path,
then decide now to choose the hard path
that leads to the life and
the world that you want.
In my experience, you will
truly serve only what you love
because service is love made visible.
If you love friends, you
will serve your friends.
If you love community, you
will serve your community.
If you love money, you
will serve your money.
And if you love only yourself,
you will serve only yourself
and you will have only yourself.
So no winning, instead,
try to love others and serve others
and hopefully find those
that will love and serve you in return.
- I was just wondering
if you had anything left
on your career wishlist?
- Sure, I never know
what's going to happen,
you know, even tomorrow.
I just got to spend the week
with some of my favorite
creative artists with The Hobbit.
It was unbelievable, what a workshop.
Made my own hobbit feet.
Next week, I get to sing with
all these wonderful artists,
doing Christmas carols.
I've done my own Christmas special.
I've had a rally on the mall.
I've testified before congress.
I may or may not appear in The Hobbit.
(audience laughing)
I get to, the nice thing about my show,
and whether or not I do the show forever,
I mean everything ends.
But whether or not I do the show forever,
the nice thing about my show,
as the host and executive producer,
I get to ask of myself,
anything that I want to try.
And but that also means I
have to do everything I know.
And so, it's just this tremendous
sort of refreshing gift.
As tiring as the show sort of is.
'cause I'm kind of
decaying before your eyes.
It's in the same way,
it's also rejuvenating.
The show is only what I want it to be.
I can always say no to myself
or ask myself something new.
But beyond this,
I just want to work with people I like.
I love the people I work with,
I love what we do
and I just want to be
able to do it with joy
and the moment I can't do that,
I got to stop and try
and do something else.
You and I have both hosted
the White House correspondents dinner.
- Yes, and I have to say I
was very inspired by Stephen.
When you called President
Bush your nigger,
(audience laughing)
I could not believe you did that, Stephen.
- Well, very few people
appreciated the courage
that took me to say it.
- I thought it was very brave.
I kind of stole it from you.
I just wanted to give you props man.
- You got it, baby,
you got it, you got it.
- You got it, baby!
- That is a really tough room.
What people at home don't understand
is that all they ever see on TV
is like the dais and a couple
people in the front row.
It's 3000 people in
there, it's a huge room.
Do you know Harry J. Lennix?
Do you know who Harry is?
Harry is --
- Oh, actor!
- He's an actor.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
no, he's awesome.
- He's a great actor.
He's a very dignified,
very talented African American actor.
We went to Northwestern
University together,
but I had not seen Harry in like 20 years
and he was there the night I did it.
And I'm on the dais and I've just finished
and nobody's looking at me.
Like no one will make eye contact
and Harry comes up
and he's at the dais
and everybody's still up there
and he goes, hey man,
that was really good.
I said, Harry, it's
really great to see you,
I don't think these people liked it.
And Harry's so wonderful, so dignified,
and just got a fantastic voice.
He leans back and goes,
fuck these people.
(audience laughing)
- He said it there?
- That was good.
- He said it there.
- Oh my god, that's fantastic.
- So Larry, fuck these people.
- Yes!
- That was good.
- That's what I'm talking about.
- What's interesting about,
I think there is union in your character
and you personally.
You're very supportive of the troops
and I remember when you
were in Iraq, right?
You got the president to
order you to get a haircut.
Pretty serious?
- That was fun, yeah, sure, yeah.
I knew I wanted to have my head shaved,
'cause I thought that'd
feel good in the room.
That'll feel good with all the troops
and I said, who could shave my head?
The General.
Who's going to make the General do it?
The president and everybody said yes,
it was really lovely.
- And I think this work you're doing
with the troops is fantastic.
Was there some reason,
in sort of growing up or something,
that you felt that way
or was it just a genuine
patriot about this stuff?
- I don't know, I'm a genuine patriot,
I love my country
and I think patriotism does not
require focus on the troops.
Do you know what I mean?
There are other ways to be patriotic,
other than association with the military.
That being said, I think
not enough attention is paid
to the men and women
who make the sacrifices
that we have collectively
decided they should make
and then ignore.
- Yes, I agree.
- You know what I mean?
We're all responsible,
we all are sending the troops
orders, you know what I mean?
And we did it without a lot of thought
but with a lot of emotion,
10, 11 years ago.
And not a lot of discussion,
and then we thought our job was done.
And so, because I talk about it a lot,
or used to talk about it more,
when it was more in the consciousness,
especially in the news consciousness
because my show was a
shadow of the actual news
and I'm, in some ways,
very reactive that way.
I felt at a certain point
that I had a responsibility,
along with my responsibility to be funny,
to take opportunities that came to me,
to talk about the troops when I can.
I have an '82nd airborne flag in my office
because very early on in the show,
a young man and his wife came
and she had to speak for him
because he had such bad brain damage
and he still could hear,
but he couldn't really converse
and he enjoyed the show
and he gave me the flag
and all he could really get out was,
don't forget us.
Please keep talking about us.
So I've got it on my wall
and I think about it
and we don't nearly do enough
and we don't help as much as we should.
But certainly, when
you have an opportunity
that fits within,
I still have a responsibility
to do a comedy show.
When I can fit those two things together,
we're more than happy to
try and make it happen
and as I said, we should do more.
When I came back to The Daily Show,
Jon was the new host
and it was a totally different show,
'cause Jon invited all of
us who were on the show.
Doing good jokes is a virtue
in of itself, but he said,
have your own opinion.
- Right.
- Bring your own passion to the show.
I want everybody to invest their own ideas
and I didn't realize I
had political opinions.
I didn't realize--
- 'cause were you political before then?
- No, no, I was always a news junkie,
but I worked very hard not
to do any political humor
because there wasn't a lot
that I enjoyed.
- Yeah.
- I like George Carlin,
which was certainly satire.
- Yeah.
- And social satire, not
a lot of political satire
and so I really admired George Carlin
and kind of wanted to be him
or be him or Steve Martin.
But didn't do political things.
I made a very specific
choice in all my work
to not even reference real
world events or real places
or who the president was.
- Why?
- Because I wanted people to
enjoy my joke a year from now,
as opposed to right now.
- And you didn't think
that current would be
relevant a year from now?
- Well, there also wasn't
a lot of it I liked.
I thought there was a lot of too many
Ted Kennedy drunk jokes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Do you know what I mean?
Which is very flippant.
- Yeah.
- But isn't really, there's
not a lot of intellectual sweat
that goes into that joke,
so I wanted to do something
just different than that.
But, Jon--
- I like that term,
intellectual sweat.
- Yeah--
- Because that really is
what your work is.
It's kind of intellectually sweaty.
- Yeah, well we're working really hard
to make jokes about ideas.
- Speaking of which, again,
many Googlers have been
asking questions about
your upcoming YouTube show.
- Yeah, what is that?
(audience laughing)
I have an upcoming YouTube show?
- Yes, we have all decided
that you have to have a YouTube show,
of some kind.
- Okay.
Does that violate my contract
with Viacom to have that?
'cause you guys had a billion dollar
lawsuit against each other, you realize?
And Sumner Redstone would rather
see your head on a stick.
- You actually asked us on television,
to give you the money, you forget?
- No, I don't forget.
You never gave it to me.
(audience laughing)
- I know, I know.
- If you gave the money,
I'd be knee deep,
- we discussed this
- In hookers and blow and I'd forget.
(audience laughing)
No, no, I was deposed.
I was deposed for that lawsuit.
- I know you were.
- And I've got a good story
if you'd stop talking.
(audience laughing)
I'm sorry, what was your question?
- Tell your story.
- Okay, okay.
(audience laughing)
So, it's been a few years
and I don't think I'm violating it,
but I got deposed for
the YouTube Google thing,
the Viacom thing,
'cause boy, they were mad at you guys.
They were so mad at you guys
and so, your all's lawyer,
brought me in to say,
well, how isn't YouTube great
and wouldn't you not have a show,
if it wasn't for YouTube?
And all those kind of questions
and the lawyer for Google
would read these statements
that I said on air
and I said, well, I didn't say that.
And he goes, no, you said it,
you said it on this broadcast.
I said, no, my character said that
and my characters not
under oath right now.
(audience laughing)
and they said, if your
character were here,
(audience laughing)
what would he say?
And so, I would say,
okay, well, I'll tell you
what, I'll tell you what.
If you ask me questions that
my character has to answer,
as opposed to me,
I'll move my coffee cup to the
other side of my place here
and then you'll know I'm
speaking as my character.
And so, they'd ask me a question
and I'd keep my cup over here.
And then in the middle of the question,
I'd start moving it over to the side,
'cause I'd realize they
were asking me something
from my character and the person would go,
let the record reflect,
the coffee cup is now on the
left side of Mr. Colbert.
(audience applause)
- You have a question?
- My characters answer was always like,
I don't know what you're talking about,
I don't know what you're
talking about, buddy.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hoped you enjoyed.
I made this video because Adam Jyun,
I hoped a pronounced
that okay, asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which of the clips
had the biggest impact on you.
What are you going to change
in your business or life?
How are you going to apply
some of the advice
Stephen had to yourself?
Leave it in the comments
and I'm super curious,
'cause I want to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a
quick shout out the Ola,
from empiretrafficacademy.com.
Ola, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one
word is, much love guys.
I'll see you soon.
- [EmCee] No one is safe,
ladies and gentlemen,
here with a special edition
of The Colbert Report, Stephen Colbert.
(audience applause)
- Thank you, ladies and gentlemen.
Before I begin, I've been
asked to make an announcement.
Who ever parked 14 black
bulletproof SUVs out front,
could you please remove them,
they're blocking in 14
other black bulletproof SUVs
and they need out.
Wow, wow, what an honor.
The White House Correspondents Dinner.
To sit here, at the same table,
with my hero, George W. Bush.
To be this close to the man.
I feel like I'm dreaming,
somebody pinch me.
You know what?
I'm a pretty sound sleeper,
that may not be enough.
Somebody shoot me in the face.
(audience laughing)
Is he really not here tonight?
Damnit, the one guy who could've helped.
By the way, before I get started,
anybody needs anything
else at their tables,
just speak slowly and clearly
into your table numbers,
someone from the NSA will be
right over with a cocktail.
Mark Smith, ladies and
gentlemen of the press corp,
Madam First Lady, Mr. President,
my name is Stephen Colbert
and tonight it is my privilege
to celebrate this president.
'cause, we're not so different, he and I.
We both get it.
Guys like us, we're not some
brainiacs on the nerd patrol,
we're not members of the factinista.
We go straight from the gut, right sir?
That's where the truth lies,
right down here in the gut.
Do you know you have more
nerve endings in your gut,
than you have in your head?
(audience laughing)
You can look it up.
Now, I know some of you are
going to say I did look it up
and that's not true.
(audience laughing)
That's 'cause you looked it up in a book.
Next time, look it up in your gut, I did.
My gut tells me that's how
our nervous system works.
Every night, on my show,
the Colbert Report,
I speak straight from the gut, okay?
I give people the truth
unfiltered by rational argument.
I call it the no fact zone.
FOX news, I want a copyright on that term.
(audience laughing)
I'm a simple man with a simple mind.
I hold a simple set of
beliefs that I live by.
Number one, I believe in America.
I believe it exists.
My gut tells me I live there.
I feel that it extends from
the Atlantic to the Pacific.
And I strongly believe it has 50 states
and I cannot wait to see
how the Washington Post
spins that one tomorrow.
I believe in democracy.
I believe democracy is
our greatest export,
at least until China figures out a way
to stamp it out of
plastic for $0.03 a unit.
As a matter of fact,
Ambassador Zhou Wenzhong, welcome.
Your great country makes
our happy meals possible.
(audience laughing)
I said it to celebration.
I believe the government
that governs best,
is the government that governs least
and by these standards,
we have setup a fabulous
government in Iraq.
(audience laughing)
I believe in pulling yourself
up by your own boot straps.
I believe it is possible.
I saw this guy do it
once in Cirque du Soleil.
(audience laughing)
It was magical.
And though I am a committed Christian,
I believe that everyone has the
right to their own religion,
be you Hindu, Jewish, or Muslim,
I believe there are infinite paths
to accepting Jesus Christ
as your personal Savior.
(audience laughing)
Ladies and gentlemen,
I believe it's yogurt.
But I refuse to believe it's not butter.
Most of all, I believe in this president.
Now I know there are some
polls out there saying
that this man has a 32% approval rating.
But guys like us, we don't
pay attention to the polls.
We know that polls are just
a collection of statistics
that reflect what people
are thinking in reality.
And reality has a well known liberal bias.
So Mr. President, please pay no attention
to the people who say
the glass is half full.
32% means that glass (laughs),
it's important to set up
your jokes properly, Sir.
Sir, pay no attention
to the people who say
the glass is half empty.
Because 32% means it's two thirds empty.
There's still some liquid
in that glass, is my point.
But I wouldn't drink it.
(audience laughing)
Last third is usually back wash.
Look folks, my point is,
that I don't believe this is a
low point in this presidency.
I believe it is just a lull,
before a comeback.
I mean, it's like the
movie, Rocky, alright?
The president, in this
case, is Rocky Balboa,
and Apollo Creed is
everything else in the world.
(audience laughing)
So 10th round, he's bloodied.
His corner man, Mick, who
in this case, I guess,
would be the vice president.
He's yelling, cut me Dick, cut me.
And every time he falls,
everyone says, stay down Rock, stay down.
But does he stay down?
No, like Rocky, he gets back up
and in the end he actually
loses in the first movie.
Okay, doesn't matter.
Doesn't matter, the point is,
it is the heart warming story
of a man who is repeatedly
punched in the face.
(audience laughing)
So don't pay attention
to the approval ratings
that say it's 68% of Americans disapprove
of the job this man is doing.
I ask you this,
does that not also logically mean
that 68% of approve of
the job he's not doing?
Think about it, I haven't.
I stand by this man.
I stand by this man because
he stands for things.
Not only for things, he stands on things.
Things like aircraft carriers and rubble
and recently flooded city squares.
And that sends a strong message,
that no matter what happens to America,
she will always rebound with
the most powerfully staged
photo-ops in the world.
Now, there may be an energy crisis.
Well this president has a
very forward thinking energy policy.
Why do you think he's down on the ranch
cutting that brush all the time?
He's trying to create an
alternative energy source.
By 2008, we will have
a mesquite powered car.
And I just like the guy.
He's a good Joe.
Obviously loves his wife,
calls her his better half
and polls show, America agrees.
(audience laughing)
She's a true lady and a wonderful woman,
but I just have one beef, ma'am.
I'm sorry, but this reading initiative.
I'm sorry, I've never been a fan of books.
I don't trust them,
they're all fact, no heart.
I mean, they're elitists
telling us what is or isn't true
or did or didn't happen.
Who's Britanica to tell me
that Panama Canal was built in 1914?
If I want to say it was built in 1941,
that's my right as an American.
I'm with the president, let history decide
what did or did not happen.
The greatest thing about this man,
is he's steady, you know where he stands.
He believes the same thing Wednesday,
that he believed on Monday.
No matter what happened Tuesday.
Events can change, this
man's beliefs never will.
As excited as I am to be
here with the president,
I am appalled to be surrounded
by the liberal media
that is destroying America.
With the exception of FOX news.
Fox news gives you both
sides of every story.
The president's side and
the vice president's side.
But the rest of you,
what are you thinking?
Reporting on NSA wiretapping
or secret prisons in Eastern Europe?
Those things are secret for
a very important reason.
They're super depressing.
And if that's your goal,
well, misery accomplished.
Over the last five years,
you people were so good.
Over tax cuts, WMD intelligence,
the effect of global warming.
We Americans didn't want to know
and you had the courtesy
not to try to find out.
Those were good times,
as far as we knew.
But listen, let's review the rules.
Here's how it works.
The president makes decisions,
he's the decider.
The press secretary
announces those decisions
and you people of the press,
type those decisions down.
Make, announce, type.
Just put them through a
spellcheck and go home.
Get to know your family again,
make love to your wife.
Write that novel you got
kicking around in your head.
You know, the one about the
intrepid Washington reporter
with the courage to stand
up to the administration?
You know, fiction!
(audience laughing)
'cause really, what incentive
do these people have
to answer your questions after all?
I mean, nothing satisfies you.
Everybody asks for personnel changes.
So, the White House has personnel changes
and then you write,
oh they're just rearranging
the deck chairs on the Titanic.
First of all, that is a terrible metaphor.
This administration is not sinking.
This administration is soaring.
If anything, they are rearranging
the deck chairs on the Hindenburg.
(audience laughing)
now it's not all bad guys out there.
There's some of the
heroes out there tonight.
Christopher Buckley, Jeff
Saks, Ken Burns, Bob Shieffer.
I've interviewed all of them.
By the way, Mr. President,
thank you for agreeing to be on my show.
I appreciate it, I was just as shocked
as everyone here is, I promise you.
How's Tuesday for you?
I've got Frank Rich, but
we can just bump him.
And I mean bump him.
(audience laughing)
I know a guy, say the word.
See who we've got here tonight.
We've got General Moseley,
Air Force Chief of Staff.
We've got General Peter Pace,
Chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff.
They still support Rumsfeld.
Right, you guys aren't retired yet, right?
Right, they still support Rumsfeld.
Look, by the way, I've got a theory
about how to handle these retired generals
causing all this trouble:
Don't let them retire!
Come on, we've got a stop-loss program;
let's use it on these guys.
I've seen Zinni in that
crowd on Wolf Blitzer.
If you're strong enough to go
on one of those pundit shows,
you're strong enough to
stand on a bank of computers
and order men into battle, come on!
Jesse Jackson is here, the Reverend.
Haven't heard from the Reverend
in just a little while.
I had him on the show.
It was a very interesting interview,
very challenging interview.
You can ask him anything,
but he's going to say what he wants
at the pace that he wants.
It's like boxing a glacier.
Enjoy that metaphor, by the way,
because your grandchildren
will have no idea
what a glacier is.
(audience laughing)
Justice Scalia is here.
Justice Scalia, may I be the
first to say, welcome, sir.
You look fantastic, how are you?
Just talking some Sicilian with my paisan.
John McCain is here.
John McCain, what a maverick!
Somebody find out what
fork he used on his salad,
because I guarantee you
it wasn't a salad fork.
This guy could have used a spoon!
There's no predicting him.
By the way, Senator McCain,
it's so wonderful to see you coming back
into the Republican fold.
I've actually got a summer
house in South Carolina.
Look me up when you go to
speak at Bob Jones University.
So glad you've seen the light, sir.
Mayor Nagin, Mayor Nagin
is here from New Orleans,
the chocolate city!
Yeah, give it up.
Mayor Nagin, I'd like to
welcome you to Washington, D.C.,
the chocolate city with
a marshmallow center
(audience laughing)
and a graham cracker crust of corruption.
It's a Mallomar, I guess,
is what I'm describing,
is a Mallomar, it's a seasonal cookie.
Joe Wilson is here.
Joe Wilson, right down here in front,
the most famous husband since Desi Arnaz.
And, of course, he brought along
his lovely wife Valerie Plame.
Oh, my god!
(audience laughing)
Oh, what have I said?
Ay, gee monetti, I am
sorry, Mr. President,
I meant to say he brought
along his lovely wife,
"Joe Wilson's wife."
Patrick Fitzgerald is
not here tonight, right?
Okay, dodged a bullet.
And, of course, we can't
forget the man of the hour,
new press secretary, Tony Snow.
Secret Service name: "Snow Job."
Toughest job, what a hero!
Took the second toughest
job in government,
next to, of course,
the ambassador to Iraq.
Got some big shoes to fill, Tony.
Big shoes to fill.
Scott McClellan could say
nothing like nobody else.
McClellan, of course, eager to retire,
really felt like he needed to
spend more time with
Andrew Card's children.
Now, Mr. President, I wish you hadn't
made the decision so quickly, sir.
I was vying for the job myself.
I think I would have made
a fabulous press secretary.
I have nothing but
contempt for these people.
I know how to handle these clowns.
In fact, sir, I brought
along an audition tape
and with your indulgence,
I'd like to at least give it a shot?
So, ladies and gentleman,
my press conference.
(camera shutters)
I have a brief statement.
The press I destroying America.
Okay, let's see who we got here today.
Stretch, Sir Nerdlington.
Sloppy Joe, Terry Lemon Meringue Pie.
Oh, Doubting Thomas, always a pleasure.
And Susanne Malhello.
Yes?
- Will the vice president
be available soon
to answer all questions, himself?
- I've already addressed
that question, you.
- Walter Crumbcake, the noted CBS anchor.
- Ah, no, he's the former CBS anchor.
Katie Couric is the anchor
the CBS Evening News.
By the way, how do you
guys feel about that?
You, toppled hair, guy in the back.
Are you happy about
Katie Couric taking over
the CBS Evening News?
- No, sir, Mr. Colbert, you?
- Oh look, we woke David Gregory up.
David, do you have a question?
- Did Karl Robe commit a crime?
- I don't know, I'll ask him.
Karl, pay attention please.
- Do you stand by your
statement from the Fall of 2003,
when you asked specifically
about Karl and Elliott Abrams,
and Scooter Livy,
and you said, I have gone
to each of those gentlemen,
and they told me they
are not involved in this.
Do you stand by that statement?
- Nah, I was just kidding.
- No, you're not finished,
you're not saying anything.
You stood at that podium--
- Ah, that's where
you're wrong, new podium.
Just had it delivered today.
Get your facts straight, David.
- This is ridiculous,
the notion that you're
going to stand before us,
after having commented
with that level of detail
and tell the people watching this
and somehow, you've decided not to talk?
- I'm sorry, what's that David?
If I can't hear you, I
can't answer your question.
I'm sorry, I have to move on, yes, Terry.
- After the investigation began,
after criminal investigation was underway,
you said (fast forwarding).
All of a sudden, you have
respect for the sanctity
of the criminal investigation?
- No, I never had the
respect for the sanctity
of a criminal investigation.
Activist judges, yes, Helen.
- You're going to be sorry.
(laughing)
- What are you going to do, Helen?
Ask me for a recipe?
- Your decision to invade Iraq
has caused the deaths of
thousands of Americans in Iraq.
Wounds of Americans and
Iraqi's for a lifetime.
Every reason given, publicly at least,
and turned out not to be true.
My question is,
why did you really want to go to war?
- Helen, I'm going to stop you
right there, that's enough.
(everyone talking at once)
Guys, no, I already said no.
Guys, guys, please,
don't let Helen do this
to what was a lovely day.
(everyone talking at once)
No, no, no, no, no, I'm
not listening to you.
Look what you did, Helen.
I hate you.
I'm out of here.
There is a wall here.
(laughing)
It reeks in there.
Ridiculous, I've never been so insulted
in my entire life, stupid job.
(dramatic music)
Condy.
Help me.
- [Security] There seems
to be a problem, sir.
- She won't stop asking
why we invaded Iraq.
- [Security] Hey, why did we invade Iraq?
- No!
(dramatic music)
- Oh.
(car beeps)
(dramatic music)
- No!
(tires squealing)
No!
(dramatic music)
(train engine)
What a terrible trip, Danny.
Take me home.
- Buckle up, hon.
- No!
(dramatic music)
Helen Thomas, ladies and gentlemen.
(audience applause)
Mr. Smith, members of the
White House Correspondents' Association,
Madam First Lady, Mr. President.
It's been a true honor,
thank you very much.
Good night.
(audience applause)